[Music]
my least favorite part of sleeping with
somebody is sleeping with somebody you
know I'm talking about after the deed
your deed you know you've done the deed
you're both glowing and high-fiving but
now it's time to sleep that's a whole
different ball of wax because I got my
whole sleep routine down pat on my back
to drift off decide to go deep wake up
on my stomach like I passed out at Mardi
Gras every night I love it
that's how I do it but no two people
sleep the same that's why it's hard to
find someone that style matches yours
perfectly everybody's unique
we're like sleepy snowflakes that is
kind of sweet like I'm reading to a
child
we're each sleepy sleepy snow cones
there was a magical snowflake that
needed and now somebody audibly went
what what I'm saying is nobody sleeps is
saying we're all unique it's the only
natural body function or as I call nach
Bob bunks
okay we all have our own way of doing
right people are always like I only
sleep on my side but nobody's ever liked
when I I put my leg like this and
my arm behind my head
everybody everybody shits the same
staring blankly forward trying to get
their mind off of what's happening
something's leaving me
don't get me wrong sometimes you merge
with a girl you have good I don't mean
sex I mean you you merge in your sleep
Styles you fit perfectly together
she's like a kangaroo and your pouch and
it's lovely I love that something wrong
with that analogy to everybody was like
like that but sometimes your sleep
Styles Clash and all of a sudden you
just got this huge breathing lump next
yeah it's just in the way oh you like to
sleep stretched out not anymore
your arms stuck under girl Mountain so
now you're James Franco in 127 hours
because somebody doesn't cuddle right
and you know what else you get to look
forward to the Morning Report of all the
weird things you do when you're at your
most vulnerable that's a nice way to
wake up what's that
Oh in the middle of the night I woke up
screamed mommy 14 times you know I'm
gonna go ahead and cancel brunch and
call my they're falling asleep with
someone there can be hard or two you
know laying there just like what was
your favorite part of the day you're
interrupting my routine that's not how I
fall asleep I always visualize things
that help me drift off one of my
favorites I pretend I'm in a canoe
filled with leaves and no one can find
it try it it works or that I'm a sniper
I love that one
now in the creepy way not shooting
anybody I just love that feeling of
being high and hidden and armed
gets me right out sleepy sniper every
time but if you fall asleep with
somebody after you've had sex you're
usually falling asleep wearing what you
were wearing when you did it which for
me it's like a black sock on one foot
underwear around the other like an
anklet I bought this at Burning Man it
looked good when I was on MDMA these are
just undies but when I'm alone I do it
right I sleep in my pajama pants I sleep
in an American Apparel hoodie hood up
curl up real tight basically I sleep
like an emo kid who just found out the
Evanescence show sold out before he
could get tickets and I mean just like
he's pain I don't want to sleep nude I
want to get that out there I don't like
sleeping nude even if you sleep nude
you're not really naked you are wearing
underwear the sheets are now your
underwear big flowing blankets of
underwear except I've never gotten
townhouse crumbs in my underwear all
over the sheets everybody gets lonely
there really are crumbs in my piss
which is fine because I sleep alone it's
fine it's my lickable sand
that's why everybody secretly loves when
the person they're sleeping with gets
out of the bed I know you're not
supposed to even if you're crazy about
them it's kind of nice when they leave
because the bed is yours again
now there's this warm area where they
were I like to spread out into that like
a flying squirrel roll myself up in the
sheets like a burrito plus if you get
lonely you can always make a girlfriend
out of pillows just put your pillow
girlfriend under your arm and cuddle it
still kind of smells like the real one
but when it gets to that 127 hours
moment you're not trapped just get up
and dropkick it into the closet
[Applause]
[Music]